wenn dann jemand wie ich oder andere
laut und direkt mit ansprechen dann
möchte man lieber diejenigen
diskreditieren oder an schlecht machen
die darüber reden ich will nur eins ich
will dass die Kinder geschützt werden
und mal ganz ehrlich neuneinhalb Jahre
habe ich mich bewiesen hatte gemacht wir
haben Gesetze umgesetzt und nicht nur
hier sondern in Österreich und noch mal
ich bitte nicht darum die Kinder zu
schützen ich verlange da rum wir alle
haben Kinder Enkelkinder oder danach
passt Kinder wir sehen sie und noch mal
pro Tag werden in Deutschland 50 Kinder
offiziell missbraucht und inoffiziell
mit Sicherheit drei bis fünfmal höher
über 18000 offizielles Missbrauch Zahlen
in Deutschland und in der Pandemie davor
haben wir gewarnt ist alles noch mal
geschrieben nachweislich wir können mal
nachlesen und trotzdem ist es immer noch
so alle Themen kommen oben warum Kinder
können nicht wählen Kinderzahl keine
Steuern Kindern nutzt der Politik
erstmal wenn sie Kohle bringt und ich
könnte so unerträglich die moraline
Gesellschaft zeigt sich in denen was Sie
für Ihre Kinder tut hat Dietrich
Bonhoeffer gesagt